- Dimanche matin, dans ce
kiosque à journaux de Téhéran,
des résidents observent
l'histoire à la une,
celle de Mahsa Amini.
Et quelques heures plus tôt,
la colère était palpable sur les
réseaux sociaux et dans la rue.
Ces femmes ont manifesté
en retirant leur voile.
Mahsa Amini avait seulement
22 ans. Elle était en visite
à Téhéran mardi avec sa famille,
quand elle a été arrêté
par la police des moeurs.
Jeudi, les autorités confirment
qu'elle aurait eu un malaise
cardiaque.Elle est morte
vendredi à l'hôpital,
après avoir passé
trois jours dans le coma.
Les manifestants croient qu'elle
a été battue, mais le ministre
de l'Intérieur a déclaré que
Mahsa avait des ennuis de santé.
AHMAD VAHIDI
ministre iranien de l'Intérieur
"Nous devons attendre les
résultats d'examen concernant
les causes de sa mort.
L'autopsie n'a pas encore été
faite alors nous ne pouvons pas
commenter".
La police de Téhéran maintient
qu'il n'y a eu aucun contact
physique entre les agents
et la jeune femme,
mais l'affaire survient alors
que bien des femmes dénoncent
cette police responsable, entre
autres, de faire respecter
le port du voile obligatoire.
" Je trouve que le gouvernement
devrait retirer l'obligation
de porter de hijab.
Celles qui ne veulent pas
le porter ne devraient pas être
obligées de le faire".
"Ils n'ont pas à créer autant de
peur et de crainte au sein de la
population", explique-t-elle.
En soirée, le président
iranien, Ebrahim Raïssi,
s'est entretenu avec
la famille. Il a ordonnée
la tenue d'une enquête.
Ici Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada, Mon